and it shall be given him
father
give me wisdom as i answer the questions
from your people
give me that said the lord
and guidance from your servant
in the writings of the testimonies
help me to make the answers simple and
clear
in jesus name we pray
amen amen
i think brother had a christian that was
submitted
so he's not here okay
first question
before you ask
ah
that's it
i prefer questions that will allow me to
clarify what i have said during the week
do you understand
now you may want to ask me who did kane
marry i don't know
are you with me
or what color
should the pastor's dress wife dress be
i don't know
i prefer this is not a command
questions on what i have presented so
that i can clarify that's just a
preference
[Music]
it's on it's on
okay my question is
[Music]
how does he do it
the question the second question
do you is
your inspiration at every level thank
you very much
all right
is this working
oh okay
when i was a little boy
in the adventist church there was an
elder of my church
who had been sick about 12 years
during that time he was in a bed
and all he read was the bible so much of
it stuck in his head
when god raised him from the sick bed
then he came back to the church to serve
as an elder
whenever he preached i noticed
that his bible was open
but he never looked at it
as a little boy i looked at him and i
said to myself i was very inspired
i would like to do that
in addition to that
when i was born in the church
we had something called morning watch
you had to memorize a verse every day
then you would recite those verses in
the afternoon in the young people's
program
everyone came young old and in between
it was just a way of life in the church
this no longer exists in the adventist
church as far as i know but that's the
way it was when i came in
that habit has remained with me
in addition to that the lord has
convicted me this is the way he wants me
to handle his word when i'm in the
pulpit
and so i have no choice
i do it
night and day
and in between
i do sitting on the plane
i do it in the shower
i do it brushing my teeth
i do it walking down the street
i do it driving in my car
when i get it in the night and i go to
the bathroom i do it until i fall asleep
again
it is not easy it is constant
hard work
and white rights
my parent and personality volume two
page 601 paragraph four
that which at first seems difficult
my constant repetition grows easy
we call that practice makes perfect
every one of us has a mind
we can remember
if we try
if we understand the value of the word
of god
it'll make a difference in whether or
not we memorize portions of the bible
to me it is life it is my work it is my
life it is my wisdom it is my guidance
it is my strength it is my defense
against the enemy of our souls based on
this morning's program so i must do it
and i just love knowing that at any time
in the day
i can just recite
chapters of the bible
recite quotations from ellen white which
i love with all my art when i'm driving
in my car there's certain pieces of
music i play and i recite different
passages to different pieces of music
and i entertain myself that way
so i urge you at any age
try
use the kgb version
and i suggest you the four d's
one
develop the desire to do it
two
have
determination
if it takes you six months as i always
say to memorize john 11 35 do not give
up stick with it stick with it what does
john 11 35 say jesus wept just two words
six months to do that don't give up the
other one is discipline
if it's hot do it
if it's cold do it
if it's raining do it if there's an
earthquake do it if there's a landslide
do it in other words nothing must stop
you
every day do some and the fourth day
ask for divine help
because you're dealing with a divinely
produced book
try it you'll be surprised how god will
bless your mind
we're assembling the evidence
we're well known for the fourth
commandment
the first word in that commandment is
what remember that's a command to use
your memory
in order to remember you must use your
memory so we are practically commanded
to use our memory remember
by the way
let me repeat at any age
if you're 89
start
your brain will be rejuvenated
well so much for that god bless you
all right
teach your children if you don't want to
do it
[Music]
next question
okay where's the microphone man
oh okay these were then i'll come back
oh all right we have a mic right here
i want a clarification on
the verse
which says
god made man
in his image and likeness
and then when the devil tempted if you
said for god knows that you will be like
god
so
where there are gods at that point
that the
devil wasn't fearing
and
to what extent
did we become
gods of god life
and the never told eve
forgot that know that in the day eat
thereof then your eyes shall be opened
and he should be as god knowing good and
evil god knows everything
so in that sense he said you would be a
scars of course when they said they did
no good and evil but in a negative way
it was never god's desire that there was
no evil
when they consumed the fruit they knew
good and evil and in that limited sense
they were like god because god knows
every single thing but they were
certainly not divine
to what extent can we be god we cannot
be god
we can be godlike so adam was made in
god's image and adam's purpose on earth
was to reflect god in everything he did
alawite writes and patriots and prophets
page 45 paragraph two man was to bear
god's image both in output resemblance
and in character education page 18
paragraph three elliot writes higher
than the highest human thought can reach
is god's ideal for his children
godliness god likeness is the goal to be
rich we are to be as much like god as
possible in the book the faith i live by
page 66 paragraph two ellen white writes
referring to lucifer god made him good
and beautiful as near as possible
like himself
so god's desire for us is that we will
develop as closely to be like god as
possible but no one can be god except
god
but when you consider that god wants us
to be as much like him as possible then
we look at how we're living surely we
should cause us some embarrassment and
creating us a desire to rise to that
level god has for us
god bless
[Music]
your wife or your partner cannot be
blamed
[Music]
addiction
and that person blames somebody
for that sin and they really can't fight
it
what do they do well the person
introducing you has a partial
responsibility yes
but when you reach the age of right and
wrong and you realize there is divine
power available to conquer any sin
any sin at all
there is no sin the blood of christ
cannot wash away there is no weakness
the brothers christ cannot overcome
no matter what the addiction is
christ died to provide power to conquer
every single sin
so yes if you were at a tender age
whoever did it has partial
responsibility but when you reach the
age of right and wrong and adulthood
surely you know there is victory in the
blood of jesus christ ella white writes
genuine conversion conquers inherited
and developed sins or cultivated sins
there is no sin that price cannot
conquer
but let us not be in the role of
introducing anybody to anything please
because god will not view you favorably
all right
thank you my good sister
who's next
there's uh
all right here we are right here
and from the
time of john the baptist until now
the kingdom of heaven suffered
violence
and the violence takes by force
what do you understand by that that's
one of the more difficult verses in the
bible
the the the interpretation i have heard
is the violence is constant battle
between the believer and satan
everywhere says it is dangerous for us
to think that by any easy common effort
we may gain the eternal reward jesus
says strive to enter in to the straight
gate the greek word means fight
as if in a wrestling match that's a form
of violence you have to fight the devil
to enter the god's kingdom so that's a
form of entrance by violence
you're not just walking smiling you've
got to fight
because there's a power opposing you
but you fight with your eyes on jesus
christ and you'll never fail
you'll be wounded
you'll bleed but you won't lose
[Music]
all right my brother
yes um is that brother joseph yes hello
to joseph
[Music]
my question is based on john 17 3
when jesus says having eternal life has
to do with
knowing the father is the only true god
and jesus christ whom he has sent
how do we
match that with john 1 1. if the father
is the only true god and jesus is god
according to john 101 how do we
interpret those two verses now
when jesus was praying
was he praying as god or was he praying
as man
he was praying as a man
as a man
jesus said that they might know the only
true god that jesus christ whom thou has
sent so yes god is the only true god the
human jesus is praying to his father and
he calls them the only true god
but the divine jesus is holy god
by the way so is the holy ghost they are
fully divine
they think we will learn in greater
detail when we cross over into the new
world can you say amen
let nothing get in the way of your
entrance into the new world nothing and
no one
uh who's next
hi
go ahead
oh your mic is not alive
uh my question is
uh in the morning
yes
baptizing
you heard me say what baptizing
yes yes yes yes
now i want to be clear on that
because
if someone
has been baptized yes
[Music]
so what's the difference because in the
bible saying there is only one baptism
one baptism doesn't mean you baptize
once it means one mode of baptism yes
come again one baptism doesn't mean you
can only be baptized numerically once
it refers as one mode of baptism
that's total immersion
re-baptism is a biblical concept let me
uh let me explain it this way
there are many young people who were
baptized because their friends were
being baptized
and they just joined in the baptism
not understanding exactly why they were
getting baptized there are some young
children who were forced by the
appearance to be baptized baptism is
more than getting wet
baptism is the outward symbol of a
change of heart and mind
many people are just
dipped but they're not changed
eloise says many have been baptized but
they were baptized alive
you followed me the old person did not
die
in a case like that when truth
really enters that person's life and the
life changes the person should be
re-baptized and so eloise writes an
evangelism page 375 paragraph 2 when a
soul is truly reconverted let him be
re-baptized i was preaching in south
korea many years ago and i made a call
for baptism of 50 people came many of
them to be re-baptized
when i met with them in an upper room a
retired minister met with me
and he told us this story
in the middle of his ministry he went to
the conference president and requested
re-baptism
the president was immediately shot and
wondered what he had done
how many wives did he have that sort of
thing
he said no i have done no such thing but
my spiritual life has been like this
no growth whatsoever and i need to start
all over with god
the president said okay i will baptize
you at night he said no no no baptize me
right in front of my church because
there are many members who need to do
the same thing and so he was re-baptized
i was preaching in a
bermuda
and a week of prayer
and the pastor the associate pastor
or the pastors the pastor's wife god
re-baptized with his son i was in
another church preaching another city
and the assistant pastor was reconverted
and got re-baptized
baptism the bible doesn't tell you how
many times to be baptized now you
shouldn't be baptized every sabbath are
you with me
but there's some of us we've walked 30
years in the church and have not grown
and at some point we encounter
genuine conversion you see my friends
many people in the church are convinced
about the truth but they're not
convicted
in other words a logical presentation
led to a decision
but the spirit did not complete the
heart you see when that conviction
occurs they request re-baptism now
someone coming from another church who
was baptized and the person had a
genuine relationship with god
if he or she feels strongly that he or
she does not need to be baptized but
accepts all our truth the person can be
accepted on confession of faith but that
is an absolute last resort in the church
because in acts 19 there are 12
disciples who had never heard of the
holy ghost they have been baptized
paul preached the holy ghost to them
having received this crucial information
they were all re-bypassed
there's one baptism which is immersion
if you've been christened you have not
been baptized
all right thank you
someone else yes good afternoon
good afternoon i have two questions
question one question one you said
something that uh a son is not going to
bear the sins of the father and the
father likewise
now i was thinking about the flood there
were
babies who died in children and even
gomorrah as it was so shall it be the
coming or the son of mine
is it going to be likewise
in relation to what you say that our
baby is going to perish does god know
the end from the beginning
does he know what kind of life that baby
might have laid if the baby had lived
yes let me tell you something one of
god's most merciful acts is to cut
someone off
let me explain why
the more you sin the more you suffer the
flames of hell
[Music]
in heaven
some people will have higher positions
than others
enoch will clearly have a higher
position than the thief of the cross
but both are equally safe are you
following me no one is more safe than
another but some will have higher
privileges the man going into far
country matthew 25 he gave five talents
to one two to another one to one
but the one who had five he got five
more the master said well done the one
who had two he got two more the master
said well done
it's not how much you have it's what you
do
and so their will god knows if someone
will live a blessed life and he can cut
the person off in mercy god cuts people
off knowing that the sooner he cuts them
off the less they suffer in the judgment
even in destruction god is merciful
question two
question two uh first corinthians 2 7
going downward says the spirit gives
wisdom
um
[Music]
does the holy spirit distribute the
spiritual gifts only to adventists
no no why no no no the holy spirit
distributed spiritual gifts to people
who are impressed now god
gives gifts to some people at first
some people are born with a lovely voice
some people are born with a capacity to
handle numbers others are born with
other things people have different gifts
now
for the church man
the holy spirit gives specific gifts to
the church for the perfecting of the
saints for the work of the ministry for
the edifying of the body of christ till
we all come in the unity of faith and to
the knowledge of the son of god unto a
perfect man unto them measure the statue
of the fullness of christ so their son
gifts are for the church god's people
but remember john 10 16 other sheep i
have which are not of this fold them
also i must bring and so god can give
gifts outside of us certainly
but he's always trying to call people to
his commandment
uh where's the microphone supervisors
okay
yes my brother
i have three questions
is that fair to have three at the same
time
i'm very serious because you may deprive
someone who has just one
okay so but here two so i just can't put
you in hell for that okay question one
question one
first timothy chapter two verse nine
in like minor also that woman had done
themselves in modern apparel
with shamefully tastedness and
sovereignty not with broadened hair
or goat or pearls or costly array
in the adventist church especially in
zambia the pets
we find churches debating
on the issue of braiding of hair on a
woman
on a woman's head
there are some churches who say it's
okay a woman can get wigs and put on
their head and that some teachers will
say you can't even go in front
and speak the word of god or even sing
because you're braided here are your
questions my question is what is the
standard that has been set forth if it
is
from the bible or from the church policy
what is the main standard which everyone
has to follow together the church does
not have a policy that tells every woman
how to wear her hair the church does not
have that the churches have apology to
tell men what ties to wear what shirts
to wear
the church doesn't have policies like
that the church has broad principles as
the bible does and under those
principles the holy ghost convicts
people now in the days of the new
testament uh women of shady reputation
would wear very elaborate addresses
we're not sure exactly what they look
like but we do know from first timothy
two and also first peter three that
there are such things as hairstyles that
belong to the world at least we can
establish that
and when someone is led by the spirit of
god i was in a video a few years ago
i was talking to young people
sunday morning and i told them
every decision you make
ask this question
is this for the glory of god
and i mean
every decision
there's a young lady in the audience
she had a
hairstyle this big
you know additions and whatever
so uh but i didn't pay much attention
the next morning i was doing one-to-one
counseling she came in and i didn't
recognize her
she had taken the whole thing off
so i said who are you she said well i
was a young lady i said oh oh what
happened
after listening to what you said
the holy spirit convicted me and i could
not conclude that i had felt this thing
for the glory of god so i took it all
off
i mean the thing was used
i never thought to take it off i never
did
but she was convicted by the spirit of
god there are some things in the ship
you have to leave to the person and the
spirit of god are you with me
and but from the bible it's clear there
are hairstyles that belong to the world
and should not be in the church but it
is not the church's position to say that
doesn't belong and this one belongs when
the spirit of god moves on the heart of
a person
the person will know
this was not for god's glory let me lay
it aside
amen question two question two
in the second question as a series
where you were answering some questions
in different countries
um
you you you tackled a question which was
based on uh
on
using instruments
in the church
instruments like drums
the guitars stuff like that
you say you you compare this to um
to someone wearing a shirt
of the bunny for the bunny they come
through
yes
a bunny could represent something else i
know what you mean so
my question is coming in this way most
of the times we do not have that those
intro the drums
but we have
recordings
of the drums in our instrumentals
we have
such kinds of things so my question is
is it about the appearance of the very
instrument or the use of the very
instrument because one can say something
so what is it
that we should
uh disassociate ourselves from
thank you we should disassociate
ourselves in the things that represent
the world
now some things that are perfectly good
have been used by the world so much that
they are associated with the world now
if you look at the rock group
what do you see
you see about four guys up front and
they're all strumming guitar that's all
be and then you have a guy on drums and
that's it
you bring that into the church that's
the that's the picture that comes into
many people's minds there is no sin in a
guitar
there is no sin in the drama now
according to what you were saying
about this church let me explain what he
meant in the united states there's a
magazine called playboy
and it usually has naked women in it
playboy has a logo the logo is the head
of a rabbit or a bunny now god made
rabbits on the sixth day are you with me
but if i wore a t-shirt with the head of
a rabbit no one would think of creation
not in the united states
they would think this guy is wearing a
playboy shirt are you with me so because
of the association
you laid aside
you're with me
let's take dreadlocks
in the 60s
dreadlocks became popular in the western
hemisphere at least because of
bob marley from
jamaica reggae there's a religion called
rastafarians in jamaica they wear this
stuff they smoke marijuana
there's a man who's called the god among
them he used to be the emperor of
ethiopia called ivy selassie they
worship him all of that is part of the
religion including the dreadlocks
now you come into church with dreadlocks
what are you saying by association
you see what you're saying
what is the association
and the question is were you thinking of
the glory of god when you chose
dreadlocks and that's the fundamental
question and nine out of ten times to
put the answers no
when god made unbelief he made them to
represent him not themselves
you didn't know what i said let me say
it again
let us make man in our image
adam and eve had no image of themselves
all they did was to express god that was
the plan many of us we want to express
ourselves and we do that by the hair we
wear the pants we wear pants coming down
we want to express ourselves this is me
no your first and highest duty is to
express come on tell me god
and that's there are no exceptions
no exceptions
each church should have a music
committee
follow guidelines from the spirit of
prophecy and the general conference has
guidelines you go online you just type
in music send the adversaries there are
written guidelines
to educate the church
follow them
but always remember
is this for the glory of allah like
right in the last days just before
christ has come the second time there
will be loud noisy music in the church
with drums and the knowledge will be so
loud it will affect people's decision to
make right and wrong decision or to make
proper decisions and she said the spirit
does not move in that kind of
environment
it was not by accident and that beacon
has to say
wait till you hear the music
and then bow
because the music would affect the
behavior
on the other side
when saul was depressed by an evil
spirit
david played an evil spirit left there
two kinds of music
one glorified satan
one honors god
when we're honest and led by the spirit
we'll be led to the righteousness
question 3
thank you question 3.
last time
i i
asked you a question concerning taking
the the reference which ellen white
makes about taking a bath on the sabbath
right and you say since sister and white
says you should do it in advance let the
boots be black at the bottom taken and
so you you said it was in that time yes
because of how bad it was yes that was a
big deal
especially exactly
my follow-up question to that is do we
have a reference because if i just add
those words it can just mean that's my
opinion now do we have a reference
the bible says let's reason together not
only for the bible where we're reading
and a white ella white counsels people
not to buy bicycles
[Music]
now
can you tell people don't buy bicycles
you have to understand the context in
which she said that when bicycles were
first invented they became a fact
are you with me and people were buying
them just to be inspired wasting god's
money she said in that context she said
don't risk god's money by myself
she wasn't against a mode of
transportation she was against excessive
use of god's money and just trying to
keep up with the latest fashion that's
all she was against but she was not
against transportation
whenever i said take your bath ahead of
time you have to study what conditions
were ellen white began her ministry in
northeast united states
it is cold in that part of the country
and also in mind
taking a ba and the winters along
you've got to get the wood boil the
water do all that stuff to take a bath
she says take the bath ahead of time
she also writes the skirt should be
seven inches off the ground
why did she write that in those days
transportation was horse and buggy horse
and carriage well the horses didn't have
bathrooms to use the street was the
bathroom are you with me so with this
horse down all over the streets with
long skirts the skirts would sweep up
all that filth eloise said at least
seven inches off the ground you should
be clear she was not setting a leg from
the knee she was setting a leg from the
ground
are you following me
you don't walk around measuring people's
skirts we don't have that problem today
she wanted them to be away from the
contamination
you know somebody with this who walk
around say
look at people's dresses eyes too short
no no
she was telling them stay away from the
filth on the ground
lift the hem
at least seven inches off the ground
all right
never surrender common sense when
studying the bible
thank you
somebody else no more three question
people please
[Music]
my question is coming in
especially on the first day of
enemy
yes
i'm reading from uh
chapter five chapter 9 verse 5
where the bible says they did no nothing
all right
yes i would love also my brother to read
for me for me
but now let me read for myself
i'm bringing from uh fifth peter chapter
three
verse 18 up to 20.
they buy for it
[Music]
christ himself
suffered when he
died for you
and with that
one day he removed
your sins
he was not guilty but he died for people
who are guilty
he did this to bring all of you to god
as a human he was killed but he was made
alive by the spirit
verse 19
and by the spirit he went and preached
to the spirit in prison
those who were
spirits
those who are the spirits who refused to
obey gods long ago in the time of noah
god was patient and waited while noah
was building the big boat
and on a few
[Music]
then my question is
according to
the first address i have read
is it true that jesus when he died
the spirit of jesus went to preach to
ancient people those people who died
in those days
the spirit of jesus indeed wants to
preach to them or not
okay that's your question
all right
are you an adventist
you're an addict
okay
let's pray
loving father in heaven thanks for the
questions
as i answer this one father give me
simple straightforward biblically
reasoned response
in jesus name we pray
amen
first peter 3 18 for christ also have
what suffered for us
the just for the unjust that he might
bring us to god
being put to death in the flesh but
quickened by the spirit
by which also he went and preached unto
the spirits in prison
which sometimes were disobedient when
once the long suffering of god waited in
the days of noah while the ark was of
preparing okay we have the historical
context what period in history is peter
writing about
the building of the ark and he's very
specific while the ark was being built
there were some people who were
disobedient to god would not listen to
most of noah's preaching now
the verse says that christ by the spirit
by which also he preached it isn't said
by which also he went
by which also he preached go to uh
first peter chapter one
that's where we are now by the way first
peter look at chapter one
read verse 11 for me
not from the easy to read version
throw please thing away
who has the king james version
how many smart people are the kings
first leader chapter one
read from first
[Music]
mm-hmm
and the glory glory that shall follow
now stop
listen to that verse again
searching what
or what manner of time
the spirit of christ which was in them
did signify who is them the old
testament prophets who were writing
they were writing about the things that
happened in the new
so they wanted to understand what
they're saying peter under the
inspiration of the holy ghost he said
they were filled with the spirit of
christ
are you with me
when isaiah wrote he was moved by the
spirit of christ so in the old testament
yes the spirit of christ was working
and it was the spirit of christ in
genesis 6 3 my spirit shall not always
strive with man
we're told in second peter chapter 2
verse 5 let's go there
second peter 2 verse 5 reading about
noah
and spirit not the old world
read on but save noah the fair person
the eighth person of creation of
righteousness stop
when did noah preach
a hundred and twenty years to the end of
the lord
he preached righteousness you can only
preach righteousness under the guidance
of the spirit of god and so yes my
brother the spirit of christ was
appealing to those in the days of noah
to accept the message of noah and escape
the flood which sometimes with
disobedience when once the long
suffering of god waited in the days of
noah the patience of god
when the bible's the same where jesus
died he got up and went back in history
to go preach the people who were dead oh
no no no no we have to be very careful
how we interpret god's word we're given
a historical context
the building of the ark you know those
flesh and blood people sometimes human
beings are called spirits
and so all that verse is saying
now the spirit that was in christ
is the same spirit
that preached to the antediluvians
warning them of the flood to come
when christ died he was in the grave
that's why when he rose he rose from the
grave
all right my brother
remember to get another version
please for your own bible not just get
another version
uh yes
my question is from the genesis account
yes i've been a little bit confused uh
from genesis genesis chapter one verse
three
uh genesis
[Music]
so now which light was this one that was
created
at first this is different from because
okay the sun moon and stars are not the
only bodies in the universe that give
off light
the universe is vast
astronomers keep discovering galaxies
they are billions of galaxies the united
states the national aeronautical space
administration i think is called they
launched abroad in 1977.
it took 40-something years to leave our
galaxy
traveling at thousands of miles per hour
the universe is vast our sun our moon
our stars they give light in this part
of our reality
but that doesn't say they are the only
sources of light in the universe
so they clearly are the sources of life
but those three were to serve
this earth
and that's the best response but that's
the question i hear all the time
someone else
my question is based on like jewish
creation
yeah you mentioned
jesus created the god acted as a
supervisor so here we go
jesus created and then god acted as a
supervisor he was an agent for god yeah
so my question was
what was the wake of the holy holy
spirit during creation
now
the bible says in genesis one verse one
in the beginning god created a heavenly
earth and the earth was enough form and
void and darkness was upon the face of
the deep and the spirit of god moved
upon the face of the water the spirit
had a role we don't know all the details
but we know the spirit had a role go to
psalm 104.
[Music]
verse 29
now sum of 104 is all about the things
of nature that's all that sound deals
with the things of nature how god
provides for nature
someone read verse 29 into the
microphone verse 29
now heidi stay faced
they'll take us away
they died
[Music]
now the spirit is somehow involved in
great we never have the details but he
is somehow a part of that process but
the one who said let there be life let
me be affirmative was jesus christ and
the father identifies christ as the
primary figure in creation
he identifies christ hebrews chapter one
verse
there's no doubt
but
christ was working as an agent of the
father also in salvation the father
saves us through christ
the gospel of the world that he gave
that's how god arranged to save us jesus
is the agent of creation and the agent
of salvation
[Music]
yes my brother yes pastor uh i would
like to find out of the
law uh-huh
[Music]
when jesus christ died on the cross some
laws are done away
you want to know if it's the ten
commandments or the ceremonial law
yes all right
let us go to romans 13.
aromas was written about 20 years after
christ died are you with me
nobody answered the priest
are you following me
romans was written about 20 years or
more after christ died rose and returned
to heaven
let's read romans 13 from verse 8.
[Music]
we read eight and nine
yes
[Music]
is
paul is preaching that 20 years after
jesus died
are you with me
now
let's go to first job even further
it was written about 60 years after
jesus died
first john chapter 5
let's read well let's go to first john
chapter 2.
let's read verse three four and five
first is three four five someone else
can read or the same brother can read
who is reading
he that
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
to help pronounce the ten commandments
my brothers and sisters listen to these
words
are you ready
patriots and prophets
be 364
paragraph two listen carefully
if man had kept the commandments of god
or the law of god
as given to adam
after his fall
preserved by noah and observed by
abraham there would have been no
necessity for the ordinance of
circumcision
and if the descendants of abraham had
kept the covenant of which circumcision
was assigned they would never have been
seduced into idolatry
neither would it have been necessary for
them to suffer a life of bondage in
egypt
they would have kept god's law in mind
and there would have been no necessity
for it to be proclaimed upon mount sinai
or engraved upon the tables of stone now
listen to how it ends and have the
people practice the principles of the
ten commandments there would have been
no need for the additional directions
given to moses the statutes the precepts
and all those things they were given to
help the people understand the ten
commandments
now go to first corinthians 5.
someone read verse 7
see if you can reason correctly
first corinthians 5 listen to paul verse
7 and let me see if you can come to the
right conclusion
who has first corinthians 5.
verse 7 listen carefully
yes may be
a new lamb even
as you are unleavened that's right for
even christ
[Music]
yeah now the passover was a ceremonial
law
christ died he fulfilled that ceremonial
law there was no more need for the
passover feast
listen to me carefully the entire
sanctuary system
pointed to jesus christ
and since you know
the only way to know sin is by the law
one of the functions of the law is to
identify sin you cannot bring up the
argument that the law was
uh crucified on the cross because then
no one will be able to identify sin
listen to revelation 22 14 and think
blessed are they the two miscommanders
that they may have right to the tree of
life now does that apply to people in
2020 and 19 yes lester that day today
that do his commandments that they may
have a right
that standard did not end on the cross
it is still applicable today
the law of god
is as applicable today as it has always
been
it is an expression of the very
unrighteousness of christ it is a sacred
as god himself
what was nailed on the cross all the
ceremonial laws
next oh my sister who raised her hand
over there
yes
what time is it
[Music]
yes sir let me pray father we're coming
to the close but continue to speak
through all of us i pray in jesus name
amen yes
my question is follow up on the one that
was asked about uh babies i think at the
flag
it seems a bit arbitrary to me
for god to
let children die who he know won't go to
heaven without giving an opportunity to
change so how can i reconcile that as
still viewing god as a loving god
knowing that even amongst us there are
people here who he knows won't make it
to heaven
what do you mean arbitrarily
um
listen to psalm 115 from verse one
thanks sister psalm 115 verse 1
not unto us o lord not unto us but under
thy name give glory for thy mercy and
for my true sake
wherefore should the heathen say where
is now their god
but our god is in the heavens he has
done whatsoever he hath pleased
psalm 145 verse 17 the lord is righteous
in all his ways
and holy in all his works deuteronomy 32
4 a god of truth and without iniquity
god cannot do anything wrong by your
sister so if he makes a decision you
don't understand you say father i really
don't understand and he's compassionate
because psalm 103 verse 14 says for he
knoweth our friend he remembers that
word does thus does not always
understand everything about god that is
why hebrews 11 4 6 says but he that
cometh unto him must believe that he is
first
that is what just right holy sinless all
of that you believe that first
then on that basis you believe is a
rewarder if we do not believe god is
just and right in everything he does we
will begin to question god's sanctity
god is always right
he's a righteous god and when he takes
an action he has a just reason we may
not understand
but god is right
and god does not really owe us any
experience
you know god owes you nothing
you didn't hear me
wish i could talk to you why god owes
you
nothing
but he wants to give you everything
ah come on say something after my lovely
sister you may not understand not why
in the new world god will make it clear
why he acted as he did look at christ on
the cross
how can a father let his son go through
that
are you with me
he let him go through it for you